in today's money watch we've got tips to
help you save money and this week by the
way is called America saves week when
all of us are encouraged to put money
away I know what you're thinking with
the cost of groceries and other items
going up up saving is easier said than
done however CBS News business analyst
Jill Schlesinger is with us to help us
save if we can right yeah so we know
that saving rates are going down at this
particular moment in time why okay so
big picture before covid the savings
rate in the U.S the personal savings
rate was 8.8 percent that was actually
pretty good and then all of a sudden
covet hits we're all home and we're not
spending money hard to spend a lot of
money when it's Bounty and disinfected
right and all of a sudden the savings
rate went way up literally 34 in April
of 2020 it was the historic High ever
wow okay so all of a sudden everybody's
feeling good we're saving it's good we
have no way to spend money then in 2022
the economy starts opening up people
start spending and inflation skyrockets
and that means the personal savings rate
right now is 4.7 percent it's again it's
not like oh my God that's the worst
thing ever but it is going down we do
want to try to see that go up again your
recommendation is what well my
recommendation is as always when you are
struggling to actually save money one of
the best things that you can do is try
to automate your life really as much as
possible now there's a little bit of an
issue here now what does that mean
automate your life well like you know
how sometimes when you have a retirement
plan through work yeah they just take
the money out and all of a sudden you're
like wow I have a 401k account that's
cool if you can do that personally it's
a lot easier to stick to a plan so you
create some way to actually track your
money I know this is the part that
everyone hates but like you just look at
how much you're spending you see if you
can free up a teeny tiny bit of money
automatically take that amount of money
push it into your savings now look the
reality is that for a lot of people they
are actually doing that but they're also
contending with high prices and by the
way debt has started to go up again so
one thing my bank did which was great is
there's like a rounding process where
any fraction of a dollar that for any
purchase you make they put that
automatically into savings which was a
great way to as you say automatically
pile up a little bit of money how bad is
the individual debt problem right now so
you know I I don't want to say this is
like raising the red flag I want to put
up a yellow flag so we've got some data
that was out recently from the Federal
Reserve Bank of New York and what we
have found is that debt levels for
credit card debt especially is starting
to they're starting to rise specifically
they are rising for the people at the
lower end of the income stream and
younger Americans I do want to put a
little red warning sign up for this yes
the 30-somethings we are seeing average
credit card balances and it's just
average but it's about 6 700 bucks it's
hard to save money if you're caring and
servicing that debt so we want if you're
gonna go look at your tracking of your
spending and you're instead of putting
money away and saving also try to put a
little bit extra on that highest
interest credit card debt first work
your way down
it's tough to make that priority choice
I know but he's not adding up at the end
of the month and you're trying to make
those automatic saving uh contributions
it's difficult stuff for sure easier
said than done as we yeah I know it Bill
Schlessinger you have had the last word
thank you that's a nice way to end nice
way to end thank you so much thank you
very much Joe we appreciate it